now we can be proud of our high
Democratic standards but we mustn't
ignore the worrying state of press
Freedom around the world
it's a trend that is also now affecting
Europe
the European media Freedom Act is a
decisive instrument to address these
challenges
media is not just any old business
over and above the economic side of
things media is part of Education
cultural development and inclusivity in
our societies and it protects
basic rights like freedom of speech and
access to information as such
Media Services dual role has to be
recognized in the European medium
Freedia act we have a balanced text that
does Justice to that Jewel role and
protects the media from external
influence we've made it sure that the
media
surveillance is politically independent
we've created transparency
about ownership and we've guaranteed
working
minimum standards for journalists
media service providers should also be
able to go to the European level when
National regulations make it impossible
for them to do their work
in addition we have included the big
online platforms who act as Gatekeepers
in our digital lives these mostly
non-european platforms have a lot of
power to decide what sort of content
gets to us or not
European media content is strictly
regulated and shouldn't be subject to
the arbitrary decisions of these
platforms we've seen many cases where
serious and legal content has been
blocked and that shows us that we need
this protective mechanism
this mechanism does not apply this
guarantee doesn't apply for illegal
content the DSA remains untouched
we're talking here about protecting
quality journalism scientific articles
and investitative journalists shouldn't
be subject to the arbitrary decisions of
big platforms we as MEPS can now show
whether we are serious about protecting
the media
media is already regulated there's media
surveillance
recognized regulation mechanisms already
in Europe or well
whether we want self-regulation now
we've achieved a number of legislative
Milestones we've already we've got
anti-slep with the DSA the dma avmd or
the copyright directive now what we have
to do is to make the media and
journalists give them security about
diversity and freedom and the European
media act represents a further step in
protecting our media and democracy and
they thought ask you to give it your
support in the vote this afternoon
[Applause]
thank you very much for the committee
and the internal marketing consumer
protection I give the floor to please
freedom of expression is too fragile for
it to be ignored thanks to the Digital
Services act and I was one of the
European Parliament um
report hers for this and it's been
important since the 25th of August
um internet search engines have the
legal requirement
to
um
to suppress any clearly illegal content
such as cyber bullying
uh you cannot harass or threaten anyone
thanks to the medium Frida act where it
was also my honor to be one of the
rapporters we um consolidate this
freedom of expression however this time
we prevent uh social networks themselves
from arbitrary takedown of content or
information
just because they are not in line with
their general rules of use or because of
the ideology of the owners of the
network
so what this means for instance is that
Twitter cannot delete the accounts of
certain journalists
hatred is illegal but censorship is
something different we're not the
American model which lets people say
anything they want nor are we the
Chinese model which people doesn't let
people say anything this is the European
cultural model
thank you very much and now for the
committee on civil liberties Justice and
home Affairs Ramona strawberry please
the European media Freedom Act was not
born from our mere appetite to create a
Sandbox to test our ability to legislate
on everything everywhere
it was born from a profound need to
protect perhaps the most important yet
the most fragile pillar of any
functioning democracy
free media
and it is not about regulating media
it is about creating the safest possible
space for media freedom in media
professional professionals why because
in spite of all soft law guarantees we
still see a great deal of abuse against
independent journalists and media
professionals Emilia Sher Khan from my
country is just one example of a strong
independent journalist who has been
standing tall and facing the pressure
and harassment until today but there are
hundreds alike
with the media Freedom Act Emily handles
like her who fight for the truth will
have an ally an ally that protects their
sources as journalists would rather face
death than reveal their sources an ally
that protects their editorial Freedom
that ensures transparency that allows
them to do their job without fear of
pressure threat or political
interference
I would like to thank again the
commission for their bold proposals to
all of the colleagues that I worked with
on this file and I'm looking forward to
securing a strong text together with the
council
every single politician who wakes up in
the morning to look for Quality news and
correct information
founding its activities and actions on
this correct information should know why
Free Press is so important and needs to
be protected
democracy will never survive in the
darkness of the unspoken truth thank you
thank you very much and I'll give the
floor to the vice president of the
commission Vera eurova please
Madam president honorable members I
think everything was set in the last
sentence of Madame strugario about the
freedom of speech and the role of media
for our democracy
and for me this is a big moment because
all started here in this house I
remember very well the debate in it was
March 2021
when
we had just another frustrating debate
about what we can and what we cannot do
and we discussed about the
of political interference into editorial
Freedom about the political pressures
about the governmental attempts to
silence free media and I remember myself
saying repeatedly we cannot do anything
we do not have the law and then in the
discussion being encouraged by your
contributions and and and your similar
conviction that the media should be
protected better I hurt myself by saying
yes we will prepare the law
and so here we are today and I have to
continue by thanking the reporters
[Music]
the reporters of the associated
committees Mrs strugario and Mr Didier
as well as the shadow reporters and
members for your intensive work on the
European media Freedom Act it was not an
easy way to get here the pressures
against this uh this law were enormous
and at the beginning you may remember
many thought that this is Mission
Impossible I'm so glad we are here today
and we discuss seriously about the
possible outcome that might create
totally new conditions for the European
media to flourish to do the job and to
be the strong pillar of our democracy
because what was the result of our
debate in 2021 was media are must not be
just
another business on our single Market
the role for democracy was and is
obvious we worked hard with my colleague
Jerry Breton and all the colleagues in
the commission to deliver what many
thought was not possible
so what we try to achieve through
through the law uh that we want to put
for the first time in EU law that states
should not interfere in editorial
decisions that no journalist can be
spied on for doing their work that no
Public Service Media should become a
propaganda channel of one party
we require transparency of media
ownership transparency and fairness in
the allocation of State advertising we
ask the media themselves to take
measures to protect editorial
Independence and disclose conflicts of
interest
there is a strong focus in the act on
encouraging self-regulation and ethical
standards we also strengthen the
European coordination of national media
Regulators with the European board for
Media Services we are creating new
mechanisms such as a mutual assistance
to ensure coordination and solidarity in
dealing with serious threats such as
Russian propaganda
the act includes new requirements for
member states should which the member
states should follow when it comes to
National measures which affect the media
and to assess media concentration
finally we propose more safeguards for
media in the online environment
honorable members you have worked
intensively and fast on the media
Freedom Act and I am grateful to see
that the parliament's report recognizes
the importance of all the building
blocks of our proposal I note with great
interest how you want to strengthen
further the protection of journalists
and the transparency of media markets I
also note the importance of the debate
in the parliament regarding how media
content is moderated on very large
online platforms let me emphasize that
the media Freedom Act is a piece of a
broader puzzle let me mention the audio
visual Media Services directive the
copyright directive and of course also
the Digital Services Act and the code of
practice against this information we
believe that there is harmony not
cacophony that all these rules and all
these pieces of legislation work very
well together
I welcome the ambition of this house to
turn this proposal into a reality this
year
we don't have much more time
but I am convinced that also with the
Spanish presidency we can achieve the
goal
I rely on
them also
we have the opportunity which we should
not miss and there is an urgency to act
so I want to thank you for your work and
looking forward to continuation thank
you
thank you very much vice president and
now we come to the speakers for the
political group starting with the EPB
group Thomas frankowsky please
commissioner
there's no democracy without free media
that's why it was became known as the
fourth estate and its role in
transparency in respect of authority and
Society has become very important
however the fourth estate has started to
lose credibility in the last few years
we're ever more concerned about the
trends that we see in some member states
of the EU
which really uh propaganda and
censorship and that's why we need EU
action as soon as possible the media can
form
public opinion and that's why we should
be very worried about the ex increase in
fake news
freedom of expression is a basic human
right
the balance of the needs to guarantee
that freedom on the one hand and on the
other hand protect users is a cautious
balance that has to be hit
we also need to protect journalists
sources that too is a crucial part of
guaranteeing media freedom
some member states offer full protection
to journalists who don't want to give
away their sources even in criminal
cases some member states only give
limited protection
or the protection is just a general
legal principle which is nothing more
than fine words
the media have a dual role in culture
and an economic role
we think that the media Freedom Act
recognizes the challenges faced offers
protection and I hope will be a
foundation which will give the media
back their original roles so
congratulations to the Rapport and the
members of The Cult committee for the
work that they have done in arriving at
this result
thank you very much colleagues now Mr
Smith
thank you president pachano the European
medium Freedom Act is an opportunity for
Europe the parliament has made a strong
choice about what side it stands on
journalistic Independence underpinned by
an ambitious regulation protecting
journalist sources is an act of
civilization and too many member states
we are witnessing attempts to gag the
work of journalists above all uh
investigative journalists there are no
healthy democracies where journalists
cannot work as they should or fall
victim to censorship we know that we
need full safeguards here that's what
our Provisions will provide they will
cover spyware they will remove the
National Security
motivation to restrict the protection of
journalists and their sources
we cannot accept any compromise that
Waters down this matter that's so
important for us
we must ensure the full Independence and
autonomy of Public Service Media
to guarantee
protection from political and government
influence they must have twofold
Independence institutional Independence
in terms of full transparency of the
respective boards and financial
Independence so that they have adequate
State funding at a time when the public
debate is impacted by disinformation we
need to protect a Public Service Media
only if free from political pressure and
financial pressure can they
fully enjoy press Freedom article 11 of
the charter of fundamental rights of the
EU recognizes everyone's rights to have
a pluralist
information and news offering Parliament
calls on member states finally to take
action on that right and putting in
practice that right and guarantees that
the big platforms can not act fully
autonomously you know in terms of
providing reliable and genuinely
Independent Media
we need balance rules journalists make
our democracy stronger
thank you now I give the floor to Madame
your favor
ites present
we have to fight for the rule of law in
the EU
and the media are a prerequisite for the
working of our democracies
in some member states the media are very
well placed but in others they are
submissive and have become a tool of the
powers that be they've become a
political tool I'm thinking of Hungary
and Poland but that risk applies to all
member states no one is immune to that
we've seen cases of Espionage we've seen
journalists murdered in Europe
this
this concentration of ownership
the media is a pillar of our freedoms
and sometimes they too
are put under pressure luckily that's
not the case in Slovenia here we have EU
legislation
it's going to be transparent
interference
and pressures will be resisted
and in that way
we will be able to protect our media
I think it's
as much as we can do with this
legislation
there is no magic wand that's going to
eliminate all problems of course
but this legislation represents a big
step in the right direction the
direction of freedom of the media and we
should be supporting him
thank you president commissioner today
this Parliament is uh making an urgent
step towards protecting democracy in
Europe because as Kofi Annan said no
Democratic Society can exist without a
free independent and pluralistic press
there are many examples which show why
having a European medium Freedom Act is
um so important for the EU in recent
years we have seen public media
transform into a propaganda arm for
populist governments media Monopoly
monopolies that um prevent plurality
governance that spy on critical
journalists and an increase of
disinformation which feeds the extreme
right
however diagnosing these risks is only
useful if we have the political will to
face them and to find Solutions and
that's what we have in this text today
it lays the bases for a sustainable
resilient and plural media environment
we need to have transparency so that
citizens know who is behind the news
that they read Independence so that
journalists can do their job without any
interference or threats plurality
we need to take measures against media
monopolies and we also need to protect
public media
their mission should never be
compromised by political interference
these means are tools to ensure that our
citizens
can have uh better information and
um with a more critical View
we know the text isn't perfect and
that's why we've proposed amendments to
improve it however as Maria ressa said
and as uh we remember when we read the
news coming from Hungary Poland or Italy
democracy is fragile we have to fight so
that we don't lose a single scrap of it
not a single law nor any defense
institution or report we know how
dangerous it is
um if we are subject to Cuts in any of
this that's why we have to stand firm
uh the greens have always done that and
will continue to do so thank you
thank you madam crook
Ed
proposal here for the European media
Freedom Act brings in Provisions that
don't relate to the single Market it's a
violation of the treaties on the
functioning of the EU which are the
legal basis for it
it also interferes in National
government's right to form their own
media markets
provisions on the media in the whole of
the EU may end up destroying media
systems in the member states
some parts could be given our support
however many Provisions don't protect
the freedom of speech for example like
the board on Media Services
which covers other services radio and
audio visual services in the Polish
Constitution we have a clear statement
of the freedom of speech and a ban on
censorship of the press these are a
clear guarantee of the independence of
the media in our country no one is
questioning freedom of the press perhaps
the commission's real goal is to
do something other than reinforce the
need of Freedom perhaps it wants to go
beyond the treaties and impinge on
National sovereignty in this area
colleagues please stick to the time uh
you've been allotted Madame Cruze now
please
commissioner colleagues Edmund Burke the
Irish
philosopher said that the media even in
the 18th century was the fourth estate
and they haven't continued to increase
their influence they're omnipresent now
this is a huge power of information it's
often envied but the freedom of the
media is one of the foundations of
democracy founded on the freedom of
expression and opinion it's our duty to
ensure that this Freedom continues to be
protected by national laws there are
several fundamental reasons why I'm
against this regulation firstly because
the commission is baiting itself on
bogus arguments that there is a European
media market and then it lies by saying
that it aims to protect media freedom
and lastly because it has imposed a set
of binding rules on all of the member
states when only some member states are
actually targeted
to support that legislative proposal the
commission tries to grab another another
National prerogative
saying that everyone should provide
information as it sees fit and then the
vote is a consequence of that
thank you and I'll give the floor to Mr
cologlu well Mr commissioner you said
that when we started working on this act
it looked like a mission impossible
what do we managed was exactly what's
happened in the cinema we succeeded in a
mission impossible
and well you know in in my country
Greece we have all the bad symptoms we
were having all over Europe we have
control by the state by the strong
financial interests we have censorship
self-service we have assassination of
journalists and also we have a spine on
journalists so this act is very
encouraging is coming to like a fresh
air for us and that's why including the
control of the of the big Platformers
platforms is very very important what
now we are doing
you said before that there have been a
lot of pressure of pressure but really
that's the role
of the good Parliament
to fight engage the political outside
pressure to to fight against Financial
interests to do the good job and to
promote the Democracy a Justice and I
wanted to thank you and all the the
other colleagues for the work that has
been done
Russo
today colleagues we must mention Julian
Assange because whenever we talk about
press Freedom or rules regarding the
Press it's our duty to uh honor the
memory by
recalling that uh without any uh guilt
Julian Assange for doing his duty as a
journalist has been cooped up for years
he sought to raise citizens awareness I
come from Sicily where unfortunately the
mafia have killed journalists like
apparently uh and others defano and
others and
or they were guilty of doing was telling
the truth the memory of Daphne Carolina
and others who have stood up for the
truth
have
like Julian Assange had a living death
sentence we colleagues must shout out
loud and clear free Julian Assange free
Assange now
commissioner
commissioner we know that
freedom of the press
and freedom for journalists and the
associations that represent them
is
essential to our democracy
this media Freedom Act
puts in place conditions that will
guarantee the
freedom
of internal external communication means
however in practice it's only going to
be possible
if we base this on
the freedom of our media
in Slovakia
during the elections
we saw problems similar
in Portugal
we saw our Portuguese parties the s d
saying absolutely nothing
this is a way that we can influence me
does for example
journalists are killed they spoke out
against corruption in Slovakia
they spoke out against the FICO
government
because they are behind the killing of
Jan Kushner but in Portugal and in
Brussels
the Socialist Party and the s d have not
distanced themselves
from what has happened in Slovakia
or the government that supports Putin's
policies
thank you very much Mr Agra Saliba
um
thank you very much Madam president the
act as to the freedom of the press is a
piece of legislation which is extremely
important particularly in the in the
times we're living nowadays where we see
many practices around the world
which at the end of the day are really
concerning as to the freedom of
expression even in the EU the freedom of
the media guarantees
to our citizens
unfitted access to information it is
also a prerequisite so that they make
free choices Democratic free choices
which are informed when they come to to
electing those who should represent us
in power
and that is why we need Provisions which
are strong on the European level so as
to safeguard a number of points first of
all we protect the the freedom of the
press we Safeguard freedom from
interference by editorial
we also guarantee pluralism through the
media safeguarding also the independence
of the media
of the public service and we also ensure
that we have an economic environment
where
free journalism can continue to flourish
and that is why editorial editorial
action is a crucial in a in times of
misinformation disinformation which
comes also comes from third countries we
need full transparency to really know
who is speaking behind the media
means that these are priorities we must
protect through our vote tomorrow the
elections of the European Parliament are
on our doorstep we therefore need very
strong regulations in order to ensure
free elections next year thank you
thank you colleagues please stick to the
speaking time otherwise I'll have to cut
you off because we're quite short on
time and I'll give the floor to madam
Madam president vice president
colleagues
the media Freedom Act is a key step
forward in affirming our European values
of Freedom of Information and protection
for journalists at European level Madam
vice president
we are particularly proud because it was
proud sorry because it's the result of
an initiative from our political group
and you
it was our initiative to say that all
Europeans have the right to free
independent uh information
we have to look
at media concentration in a more
effective manner when it comes to
concentration of uh illiberal powers or
when it's private groups of questionable
background and particularly uh satisfied
with the fact that
um my Amendment for
Content generated by AI without any
human control is in the text because
this is key to fighting disinformation
and to ensure quality journalism in the
future
thank you and now give the floor to Mr
freund
foreign
members of the House
this is what media diversity looks like
in Hungary under Victor Orban today
imagine a colleague as you know we can't
show images in the rumors
there are no free radio TV or media in
Hungary the situation is not worse
anywhere else in the EU however other
countries are starting to follow suit
on the right of this house
there are people who only want to see
the Press praise them rather than
criticize them so protecting media
freedom in the EU it comes at the right
time perhaps a little bit late
what we agree on here will take us a
step forward protect journalists uh
transparency about ownership
concentration and how much money
governments give to media that supports
them
we also have to be honest
this proposal won't change the situation
in Hungary
when National
control fails the EU must be able to
step in in defense of media diversity
media has urban has complete control
over the media and we have to have a way
of putting an end to that
worried concerned lesson letters from
Brussels won't stop Mr Orban we have to
actually put that control into place
Auburn has to be stopped the Kashmir has
to be stopped vote for this report of
yours because otherwise we won't be able
to do what we want to do which is create
media Freedom it's
do you call it the discussion here is
not about the so-called media Freedom
Act
a label given by the European commission
to these regulation
but the media surveillance control and
censorship act which accurately describe
the nature of this regulation
it is unacceptable that the European
commission claims to promote the media
Freedom while in fact this regulation
opens the doors for journalists their
employers that live on their families to
be subjected to surveillance and spying
by the security agencies as the shadow
rapper Tony Lee before the ECR group a
cable amendments aim to eliminate the
provisions that permit such spying and
surveillance or journalists but they
were reject it by Epp snd and renew
Joseph Stalin said and I quote the Press
is our party's shaped and most powerful
weapon clearly under the leadership of
Ursula wonderla and the European
commission does not desire a free press
but rather a propaganda machine which is
tightly controlled and subjected to
surveillance like he was in the Soviet
Union the dangerous president
established by the so-called media
Freedom Act regulation will have
unreceivable and devastating
consequences for democracy and freedom
of the speech throughout the European
Union which is why as the parliament too
heavily reject it thank you
thank you president
the um draft regulation on the media
Freedom establishes standards for the
internal market for information
this is an ambitious project to protect
pluralism in the media within the
European single Market
however there'll be a European
supervisory body rather National
clearly interference from the inter
freedom of International Information has
to be prevented because this could lead
to additional limits on National
politics if they don't respect Brussels
and lead to infringement procedures
perhaps
we don't want to see any interference
from the European Union
because
freedom of press is one of the key
principles of our democracy thank you
madam Daley
grazia Presidente later today we'll vote
on whether to ban the deployment of
spyware against journalists in the EU
the media Freedom Act is the very first
time the EU is going to legislate on the
issue of spyware a technology described
by Edward Snowden as being like a
nuclear weapon and it is there are no
circumstances where its deployment is in
line with fundamental rights it takes
over your devices spies on your every
move everyone you come into contact with
it can even send messages from those
devices it obliterates the very concept
of privacy and undermines the right to a
fair trial and as it currently stands we
are today proposing to empower
governments private entities and more to
use it against journalists now for God's
sake we never stop talking in here about
defending journalists the danger of
authoritarianism Freedom into the media
if you care about defending journalists
you must ban spyware it's the least you
can do support our amendments in this
regard
Mr
hello
thank you the European
media Freedom Act
well we
know that uh it's going to be
implemented in cooperation with the fact
Checkers in Croatia the freedom of media
is uh very low the ruling party is
paying for the ads so that those media
would write favorably about the
government Mr Planck which our prime
minister
is pushing through a media act which
will empower the Publishers to reject
the publication of critical articles and
also editors will be for we will be able
to force the journalists to reveal their
sources
um of course the use of Facebook and
other social media it might be an outlet
for those freedoms but there we have the
fact Checkers waiting for them in Ambush
we're talking about the erosion of
freedoms we're talking about the failure
to respect the scientific debate
scientific facts we saw that during the
covet crisis how the fact Checkers
operated in that area an area and we are
now we now have thank you Mr Thomas
please
thank you madam president
Madam vice president of the commission
Mrs Yoruba in this new legislation you
above all emphasize mentions to protect
the public media you're talking about
the mandate
of the administration and the various
measures to protect against pressure in
Slovenia we have witnessed an incident
which
is completely against this legislation
the
left wing Coalition changed the
legislation
that will now allow
for the
uh suppression of the voices of
journalists who don't agree with them we
talk about Slovenian radio television
you were aware of this you did nothing
against it even when you were claiming
that you were protecting
journalists so why have you said nothing
is it because the Slovenian government
belongs to a party you're close to
in the case of Slovenia you're not
supporting editorial Independence nor
the public media but you are protecting
those who are destroying all of that can
you explain to the citizen of Slovenia
what you plan to do
to demonstrate your credibility this
time what do you plan to do
to palliate the effects of what has been
done to damage Slovenian media Freedom
will you yourself respect your own
legislation
thank you Mrs John Shiva
colleagues
we do propose
a media act which hopefully will change
the media medium subordinated media
pressure on journalists by governments
and business interests coalescence
between political power and media this
is the reality in Europe today and the
decline of trust to the public and
private media is logically reaching a
critical low the purpose of this act is
not to impose censorship or regulate the
media the purpose is to loosen the grip
of business and authority and create
conditions for independent journalism
the European Parliament today is about
to
guarantee protection of journalists from
pressure and the use of any method
methods of wiretapping or spying
we propose clear measures to shed light
on the property on the ownership of
media and their financial sources we put
an end to the arbitrary to the Slanted
distribution of Euro funds colleagues
European act for the freedom of media is
the result of hard work in years of
pressure the hard negotiations with the
member states will are ahead of us
hopefully today with a vast majority
will take a first initial step to
restoring the freedom in Independence of
Journalism in Europe and I would like to
thank the commissioner Euro for having
done this
thank you Mrs
president thank you president
commissioner without truth there is no
democracy without a journalism which is
truthful and verified information there
is no democracy protecting journalists
and journalism is therefore one of the
two or three uh most important
challenges of the 21st century and I'm
speaking personally here for me this uh
act remains
half done
does uh self-qualification uh subject
have the effects of means of
communication no
um is it an extra guarantee is an extra
guarantee needed for online media
against possible arbitrary large
platforms yes article 17 of the culture
committee could be improved but it's
better than the commission's proposal
because
um
the commission once again runs away when
it comes to handling this issue of
harmful or illegal content and passes
the book back to large platforms and um
generates a problems uh this article is
not ready and we're going to pass on the
responsibility to much more opaque
negotiations between Parliament and
Council however this is public law and
what we're doing is undermining
um a trust in legal certainty and this
is what we need and the gaps that we are
leaving will allow a populist to come in
and to enter power and once we're we'll
um convert this into personal
opportunism thank you Mr Collier please
thank you madam president
vice president
colleagues
we have been waiting for this
legislation for years and finally we got
here today
the attempts to paralyze free media to
destroy critical voices to attack
journalists have multiple names in
Europe
Urban
babish
Kaczynski yansha they hate free media
to silence to take control to make them
starve
that is their recipe to destroy the
voices that criticize them that is why
the European media Freedom Act is one of
the main successes of this parliament in
fighting against oligarchs
and in preserving democracy and the rule
of law in Europe
at last there will be an instrument that
will oblige media to be transparent
about their ownership structures
there will be a database of media owners
where every citizens every citizen will
easily find out who stands behind the
newspaper they read
for instance do you find do you find out
that an owner of a new service also owns
coal mines well it easily explains why
they constantly write in their news that
our fight against the climate change is
counterproductive
what I have personally fought for and
consider my biggest success in this
legislation is a ban on media ownership
for top politicians Prime Ministers
ministers commissioners
coming from czechia I had experienced
years of buyouts of free media by a
media Tycoon and a prime minister in one
person for once Andrei babish has been
an inspiration for my work needless to
say
a horrendous one thank you
thank you president medium Independence
and diversity are of course important
objectives in Sunday's speeches
everything seems to be fine we have
democracy in most EU countries and media
is said to be independent however
reality may be different
more than we think and now I talk about
Finland horse media landscape I know the
best
in Finland I've come across with
situations where medium Independence has
been affected directly by ownership by
media owners themselves especially those
media owners who are active in politics
or support politicians in elections can
easily influence media contents
and
in this way obtain positive press and
election success for themselves and the
candidates they support this often leads
to good business as well of course
there's a risk of reduced credibility
sooner or later therefore I welcome the
objective that media ownership should be
made more transparent thank you
thank you
ladies and gentlemen freedom of the
media is a fundamental principle that
anyone sincerely devoted to Liberal
democracy must defend and that but
nevertheless I disprove the disapprove
of the text submitted for our agreement
for three reasons firstly media freedom
is the exclusive competence of the
member states the legal base chosen to
justify the interference
of the EU article 174 of TF EU is
completely wrong as the French National
Assembly the Hungarian National Assembly
in the bundesrite have said then the
instrument the regulation not a
directive
expresses the attempt of the EU to
impose media conformism on the national
press and then lastly horrifyingly it's
about
taming the media that resists European
heterodoxy in France as far as vassar's
group is concerned in Hungary and
elsewhere you say media is in danger but
in fact it's the EU that threatens it
thank you
this is
pined only
colleagues National Security is not a
sufficient motive to surveil spion
journalists and make them keep quiet
in Europe sovereignty belongs to the
people and they have the right to know
the truth
um including about uh State structures
that are focusing on interests other
than the common good if we're to allow
this National Security exemption in the
regulation it's very risky because it
means that it might undermine the work
that we've done on pluralism
transparency and Independence of the
media it's also important to protect
journalism from um concentration of
ownership from the large online
platforms we agree that we want to avoid
disinformation but what is
disinformation
are we not running the risk of just
allowing uh mainstream thought to
circulate and that way we will eliminate
critical voices under this excuse I just
have to remind you that other opinions
are not disinformation
thank you Mr heltziki
president commissioner members of the
House the media Freedom Act is perhaps
the most important piece of legislation
of this parliamentary term there are
important projects the budget and what
have you but without the free media
without protecting journalists rights we
won't have free elections we won't have
democracy I think that goes without
saying
this document is the result of the
successful work of two parliamentary
committees and the investigative the
committee of inquiry on the Pegasus
scandal journalists must be protected as
must their sources and we should
honor those journalists who have died in
exercising their profession
the negotiation work has been rapid I'm
a little bit worried to see this empty
seats here and I'm not surprised to hear
the Polish Law And Justice party Express
a negative opinion about this document
because they're worried about freedom of
expression
I call on the council to
adopt this document as quickly as
possible thank you
thank you please
evos
thank you the free expression of opinion
the freedom of the press these are the
cornerstones of our democracy and it
always has been the press that worked in
the underground during uh
the world wars
included and now there's a new threat to
our media we see that there are major
online platforms
acting as
a Clearinghouse Gathering things
together that's fine but there are some
platforms with opaque rules and
free media articles disappear on them
that's not okay that worries me and
that's why I'm happy that this European
media Freedom Act will carry on the work
that we put in place with the digital
Services
act which began it we are strengthening
media freedom and
censorship and opaque rules must be kept
away it can't be musk or Zuckerberg who
determine what articles are supplied but
free publishers
thank you
I would like to congratulate colleagues
and Commissioners for the work that
you've done we have to fight for freedom
of expression
but
we have
um a terrible
um obstacles in a way particularly in
Greece and in comparison with other of
the 27 member states and I'm speaking as
a former journalist
and
the former owner of a former media owner
my
media was suppressed
the information that we wanted to
publish was not allowed to be published
for 18 months
pressure from the government meant that
we were not able to do our work we have
to continue our fight against this
colleague
being slandered
on an Italian media site
she it was said that she was corrupt and
that she was involved in Qatar gate that
is a multiple series of lies that
damages this house now this colleague
was able to get the article taken down
and defend herself but by that stage it
had got so far around the internet that
her name was associated with that in the
internet searches
information moves very quickly around
the internet
sound researched journalistic work can't
keep up with
the algorithms that push information
article 17 is going to allow fake
news and the Hungarian press is using
its own regulatory body to allow this
information so please vote for the
article 17 deletion Amendment media
freedom is important but citizens also
have a right not to be overcome well
flood of Lies
this is shenyon
in politics nothing
comes about by chance that's what
was said by a former U.S president in a
debate on media Freedom now this
legislation is coming to a head and
you've already applied pressure threats
and financial sanctions against the
countries that refuse your dictate you
are using this final straight to try and
seize control of the media against the
people and putting Nation against Nation
your draft is aimed at media
surveillance and a framework of rules
that work around the back of national
parliaments with the legitimately
elected members of those and there
should be no uh discordant voice for you
against the commission and that's why
you did this on the 9th of June press
Freedom means
above all respect for the plurality of
opinion and this is a particular serious
issue media Freedom you shouldn't act as
you are to try and
tether it and this just underlines your
disdain for the historic democratic
values of our continent
thank you
Mr
kalakovich
media and Truth
in order to go back to normal human
values
CNN Reuters Associated Press
deutschevelop and similar media Fanatics
and Taliban should be declared terrorist
organizations
during the so-called pandemics and
Forest Wars they have been producing an
enormous amount of fake information
spreading hatred among people and
Nations and as a consequence we now have
millions of victims throughout Europe
and the world
this is not an act on the freedom of
media it is an act on the freedom to
spread fake news and hatred leading the
world back into the dark days of
totalitarianism thank you
Mr bilchuk please
colleagues the European media Freedom
Act is an excellent news for media and
democracy in Slovakia we have been
facing foreign intervention by the
Russian Federation for years and
specifically from the beginning of the
Russian aggression in Ukraine Russia
spreads its influence via disinformation
fake news and various clandestine
websites political Big Shots also help
them and please let us not turn a blind
eye to it I'm also talking about fitzos
Smith that won the Parliamentary
elections in Slovakia on Saturday
that is why we need Strong high quality
and healthy media environment we need to
constantly persistently protect the
independence of the media journalists to
give them greater freedom in their work
to make them able to bring verified
information it is a prerequisite for
democracy not only in Slovakia but all
over the world we need a journalists to
be able to focus on their work and not
on the consequences of their work for
themselves and their families I am glad
that this
media Freedom Act is a modern act which
reflects how unbelievably the media
environment has changed in the past
decades the big media platforms are the
media Market stakeholders and they
cannot pretend that they do not have
anything in common with the media
environment they do they co-create it
and we have to react to this reality uh
influencer joint with responsibility
journalism a healthy information
environment are our health and one of
the prerequisites for a Bible uh
democracy like many colleagues said we
know we're aggressive attacks against
journalists lead we know how societies
we're fair and objective reporting is
jeopardized look like just always uh
remember Yankee can definitely
oh I believe that our new European
legislation will be a strong instrument
for freedom and high quality
thank you very much Madame guillon
please
Madam president vice president
colleagues
we began examining this regulation a
long time ago it's going to determine
how we guarantee freedom of the press
and pluralism of the media in Europe
when we were reflecting on the threats
and dangers facing us certain countries
sprang immediately to mind because the
situation of the media in those
countries was of concern since then
these bad examples have shown that
freedom of the press is actually under
threat everywhere in Europe in all of
our member States freedom of the press
is fragile and this regulation is not
going to be a luxury
it allows us to analyze very specific
and sometimes sensitive situations
questions of media concentration
editorial Independence and question of
questions of protecting journalistic
sources which is something we cannot um
back down on
these Provisions will be safeguards to
protect the freedom of the press
journalists and the pluralism of the
media which is what democracy depends on
it thank you Ms assalani please
thank you madam speaker Madam
commissioner esteemed colleagues this
Union defends democracy let that be
heard
when authoritarian leaders within our
Union are silencing the voices of those
who oppose them
we will push back
when this information solves its dark
seeds online or offline we will shut
them down
when journalists are attacked
spied on or silenced or prosecuted we
will protect them
when politicians can't keep their hands
off the free media
we will slap their fingers
when free speech is threatened or silent
we will slam a big ass law on the
European table
because this Union protects democracy
let that be heard thank you
thank you very much I'd like to give the
phone out to Mr come on
thank you very much president
a journalist
Ms levio was arrested at her home and
the house was searched a media outlet
that was bought by a billionaire and an
audio visual company that was completely
deprived of its financing all of this
makes the European media Freedom Act a
necessity necessity for all of Europe
because the threats that I just listed
to you are not things that are taking
place just by in Poland and Hungary they
all start taking place in my country
France the European Parliament should
strengthen this new regulation we know
that vis-a-vis the council
negotiations are going to be extremely
difficult many of our governments do not
hide the fact that they are fighting
Freedom including France and there is a
threat against media by the government
of macron this is shameful for Europe I
count on the Parliament and the
commission to not let this take place
thank you very well Mr vilinski please
thank you sir thank you very much
ladies and gentlemen
the EU is looking at the topic of
Freedom we have the position we have the
impression we're asking a dog to look
after a sausage that doesn't work we've
seen it
with the
Service Act
Czech news is
threatened by political bodies and the
want to we want the authorities to check
what is fake news and not what is
propaganda and not I don't know how you
can have the idea of
having that done by a political body I'm
in favor of media freedom and plurality
and democracy and then the authorities
must never select what is true or not
that we have the limits of criminal law
for that and what we're talking about
areas of freedom in medium you can't how
have the idea of having a European
Authority which should judge whether
media Freedom exists or not I think
I think that who
want to open up the whole area I think
that's the wrong way if one we would
like to do something
and
we should have prosperity and the right
to speak freely for everybody and not
what we're doing here
thank you now Ms said zenoka please
thank you
I'll get this Lithuania
suffering six year sentence in prison in
counters
Vladimir Slinderman Slater his trial
will start in one hour in Riga
both are prosecuted just for doing their
job as journalists
I posed the question
whether the New Media Freedom Act will
help to avoid such situation and stop
prosecution of journalists reveals a new
board
view able to do it no no in such a
proposal where this board will consist
just of functioners delegated by member
states there is another version just to
hold pan-european elections
the elections of the board
with
very famous well-known journalists are
standing for elections and to help them
alongside with European Parliament
elections it's not my idea it's the idea
of famous Italian journalists and
[Music]
the same approach can be applied to
national elections of this supervisory
board on media only in this case we can
achieve the goals posed and formulated
in the European Freedom media Freedom
Act thing
thank you very much just keep an eye on
the time and I'd like to give the floor
now to Ms fluconen please Madam
president commissioner free Independent
Media is a Cornerstone of our democracy
and we as a politicians we have to
protect media Freedom also in the cases
when maybe they are criticizing Us in
the news
freedom of expression and rule of law
they are core values of the European
Union
it's a shame that we have member states
where journalists are oppressed or spied
or even murdered because of their work
for sharing information
this media Freedom Act is well needed we
have to protect media pluralism and
freedom everywhere in the EU
digitalization poses also new challenges
for journalism when citizens are often
getting their news via social media and
then it's actually the online platform
that decides which content is shown for
the users
we already have now the digital Service
Act which brings more transparency to
the very large online platforms now
these legislations legislation on media
Freedom offers additional protection
against unjustified removal of
professional media content and this is
well needed
thank you I'd like to give the floor now
to Ms Jay
dear colleagues
imagine beginning your day with a cup of
coffee and your trusted local newspaper
you flip through the pages catch up on
the latest news on town from education
to traffic update cultural events you
finish up with the results of the local
sports team and the weekend's fish soup
cooking contest
like not such an unusual image is it
and now we imagine that you wake up one
day and
hola that is gone
and in the same newspaper now you can
read about the many achievements of your
great leader Victor Orban or about
totally absurd conspiracies on Brussels
forcing sex change operations on
toddlers well colleagues this is what
has happened in Hungary 400 local
newspapers were merged into one single
monstrous conglomerate called keshma
which is stopped with taxpayers money
state advertising makes up 75 percent of
its ad revenue and Urban's favorite
oligarchy luden Smith sarosh has control
over all of it and for too long we have
waited for the EU to address this blade
and attack on media Freedom now the
European media Freedom Act is finally a
step in the right direction because it
directly confronts the critical problem
of media Market concentration the 15
ceiling on state advertising could be an
absolute Game Changer and our
democracies will be held here if it's
implanted thank you very much
there is a blue card for you from Ms
jimbasket the floor is yours
foreign
[Music]
I hope the you can hear the translation
let's say Mr organ's friends what about
media owned by
another figures for example a lot of
meat in Bulgaria are related connected
or or owned by by Circus close to Mr
Source what is your opinion because
there they are forming public opinion in
Sofia how will you recommend this thank
you
well I suppose that
was this strong European level
regulation so that it can create a level
and equal playing field for every media
ownership and this is why I think it's
very essential to have European level
regulation thank you
thank you
very much I'd like to give the phone out
to Mr Simon
foreign colleagues
the media Freedom law is an important
step in promoting and protecting freedom
of expression and plurality in Europe we
are worried about media concentration we
want to establish standards for Public
Broadcasting
um protection of sources and and prevent
the installation of spyware and of
course this is a European issue
but as always when the EU tries to
harmonize something people are concerned
that National systems are going to be
changed by European regulation but in
this case I think that journalists will
benefit from this legislation in all
countries because lack of pluralism in
the media is a problem
in more member states than we would
actually assume and I'm very grateful to
Sabine my colleague for having brought
Harry immense experience to bear and a
lucid eye to this legislation because
when I hear what is coming from the
extreme right wing it sounds as if
freedom of the media is in danger when
the Europeans try to regulate and
so I think today is a good day for press
freedom and pluralism so many thanks to
Sabino for hayen and all the colleagues
who worked so constructively on this
file sorry sorry thank you you have a
blue card for you
uh
[Music]
Mr Joker I will speak Polish
colleague I have a question
you talk about
the right you talk about media
concentration
on the right
what do you say to burn that perhaps
here in the European Parliament we could
have a ranking
of ownership structures of the media
throughout Europe
why I'm asking this in Poland 50 of the
press
has a German owner and 70 of the TV
also has foreign owners my question is
perhaps we should take a look at that
the media the ownership structure of
media throughout Europe what does it
look like
yes of course we should look at this and
we are looking at this it is all
transparent this information is
accessible but there's a big difference
media concentration
the question of uh which media in held
in the ownership of one person or other
is one thing but the abuse of a monopoly
position and the intimidation of
journalists is something else and that
is what is happening in the country in
question in a serious way of calm thank
you now mrsovka please
Madam president
commissioner
today here we are looking at the
European medium Freedom Act and I should
like to thank
our reporter Mrs verine who factored in
a number of amendments
now this meant that this act really
assisted in strengthening the
transparency of media Outlets member
states will have to respect these rules
and we will have to also it will also
address a state advertising and a
heightened level of transparency with in
this context
lest we forget the freedom of media is
something that is absolutely crucial
within the member states and therefore
by way of conclusion I'd like to pay
homage to
someone who
JP mcleman during the war in Croatia
fought for medium free media freedom
for yugos for the the media of from
Yugoslav slavia spread lies
and this American citizen waged a war
during
editorials during the war meaning that
citizens really know the truth
today Europe is different nonetheless we
must offend media so that we make sure
that authoritarian regimes cannot
control the media Outlets thank you
Mr Mandel please thank you very much
Madam president colleagues
if we talk about the great Innovations
and Innovations
we talk about book printing or
electricity penicillin maybe but also
press freedom is a huge innovation
just like Parliament parliamentarianism
and we defend press freedom in Europe in
difficult times because in the internet
age we have so much negative in the in
in in the media disinformation hate
speech fake news
this splitting of our societies
so press freedom is so important it
means that we can have information which
is checked which is researched that you
can trust because journalists are behind
it who know their job and like doing it
and have ethical standards and that's
the big difference just like with food
we wouldn't
eat toxic food but we're all confronted
with toxic information
to have good reliable information
research information that's why we have
press freedom and that's something we
have considered very important in Europe
now we have 10 minutes because at noon
we must vote as you well know therefore
we won't be able to take all of the
speakers under catch the Eye I'd like to
begin now with Ms glavac please
thank you very much Madam president
first of all I would like to thank Mr
hayen for this excellent document
as a former journalist I welcome
everything that the parliament is
proposing here the digital
transformation is a powerful force for
Change and
therefore we must pay very close
attention to developments journalists
face huge challenges and it's very
difficult to distinguish between the
truth and fake news
journalists of course pay an important
role because they have to address this
analysis every day I think we need to
protect media and freedom and I welcome
the new board that is going to be set up
is a big step forward in order to
protect pluralism and the diversity of
the media in Europe and to develop this
further
I believe there are other measures too
that would strengthen media pluralism
and protect it further from inadmissible
interference from Spy software and
intimidation and of course finally the
protection of journalists
is not just the protection of the
profession it's the protection of
democracy thank you Mr Lopez
without free access to information we
don't have any democracy
and we know this uh
we've known this now for 250 years since
the establishment of the US and the EU
also is well aware of this freedom of
the press is fundamental hence the
proposal that we are making here we need
transparency independence of media
Outlets protection from slap and
cases against journalists or any threats
or
persecution of them this is a correct
step in the right direction for history
and it's important in the implementation
of the chart of fundamental rights in
the EU what we need to know is that it
is time for information media and press
be a part of the fundamental rights of
the democracy and we know that the
commission informs the liby commission a
committee on this as consistently we
think that this should be a part of
their information that they provide
thank you very much
Mr Keller
um European media Freedom Act and we
have to ensure and protect the Integrity
of Journalism and the media profession
itself not every government is a benign
one that you know will allow media to
flourish to be plural and to be diverse
and we've seen that in Europe the rowing
back of civil rights of fundamental
rights in certain areas and that also
means the rolling back of the freedom of
the media it includes intimidation and
persecution and use of AI in spyware and
many others in observing and monitoring
journalism is something that we have to
to root out so I do support any measures
in that context the overconcentration of
media ownership is a significant issue
of course the most important thing is
that we don't have an over concentration
of editorial influence and that clearly
is a very significant challenge today
not only in terms of monopolies from an
economic perspective but ensuring that
we have a plural diverse editorial
content across our media platforms and
our media in general in the European
Union the start emphasis should be that
press freedom is a Cornerstone of
democracy and if we want to hold
democracy in the Integrity of this the
media Freedom pluralism and diversity of
content is critically important
foreign
the Press freedom is the Cornerstone of
our democracy
it must become a model so that we can
defend the rights of journalists
throughout the world
for years here we denounce threats to
the debt press freedoms around Europe
given as assassinations and arrests of
journalists control and concentration
opinions surveillance and intimidation
violation of source secrecy and other
protections the absence of the council
today is very striking the medium
Freedom Act is a set of rules for press
freedom for pluralism and protection of
journalists in Europe but the moment is
come
for one of the recommendations of our
Pegasus Committee of requirement inquiry
a ban on spying on journalists that's a
message to our governments above all
press Freedom Is Fundamental for the
rule of law and democracy is necessary
at the time of huge disinformation let's
protecting it and let's re-establish it
thank you
Mr ilteach please
thank you very much
a
classic regulation on media would be
what we need and here we have a small
one for Google Facebook
Etc and for traditional media Outlets we
should have a more limited approach
we have promoters of a certain ideology
here
we have an accessible space for all and
in the past we recognize the fact that
there was a censorship
regulation but not though for those who
were in charge of the media Outlets
so until we can find a Level Playing
Field this will not be effective this
report is a report that is missing the
mark for us to be able to defend a true
and fair information the question is is
this something that we did on purpose or
not
been towed as a measure to protect media
pluralism and Independence in the EU
yet every European civil liberties grew
aborted salt or up in arms about a
number of measures in the text that put
media pluralism and Independent Media in
the foreign line for example article 17
which will create a two-tier media
system in the online World very large
online platforms such as Twitter and
Facebook will be entrusted with media
content moderation Powers based on a
system of self-declaration of media
Outlets that bought privileges Legacy
Media groups and allows for those groups
to publish false stories that may remain
on the site for long enough that the
disinformation has spread for long
enough already and done as damage before
is taken down through mediation process
article 17 is a dangerous provision
that's Taylor Made for abuse as is
Article 4 which proposes to empower
governments and others to use spyware
against journalists this is madness vote
against articles 4 and 17.
colleagues
I just want to clarify that we accepted
only one request per political group for
catch the eye and we took first come
first uh first serve I'd like to give
the foreign auto commissioner eurova to
reply thank you
Madam president honorable members thank
you very much for a very interesting and
important debate well not everybody was
happy and is happy about and with the
European
media Freedom Act uh at democracy and uh
I think that the result the overall
result of this discussion is that uh we
might be entering a very important phase
of dialogue when we will try to find the
best solution for better protection of
journalistic sources protection against
the spyware also uh to set the
well-working and good system to balance
the powers of the online platforms and
and the media
uh because uh several of you mentioned
that uh the role of media in uh fight
against this information well this is
indispensable and this is something
which also has to be uh protected as a
role of media while of course always
keeping the freedom of speech and and
pluralism in opinions we do not want and
we are not regulating opinions but we
want to prepare better conditions for
those who have the power and who are
professionals to get the effects right
I want to react in a remaining 40
seconds on the criticism yes we do have
a legal competence to do that it was
confirmed by the legal service of the
council and yes we need the media
Freedom Act because we do not want to
get to the situation which I experienced
25 years of my life in Communist Regime
one state one party one Doctrine and
state information Monopoly forget it
this will not happen in the EU and I
think that the media Freedom Act is a
very good uh solution and Tool against
that uh last words go to Madame Diana
riba you mentioned
I will meet her in Japan in few days and
she told me last time we met how she
loves the media Freedom Act and so I
will deliver I hope good news that we
are going in the direction of having
this adopted thank you very much
thank you very much before I give the
floor to the reporter I should like to
call on the colleagues to please be
quiet
could we please allow the speakers to
speak without disruption thank you very
much to your colleagues for this very
intense debate and thank you also to all
the teams the secretariats the the
offices of my uh Shadow reporters and of
course the general reporters who did an
excellent job
with the cult committee text I think we
have a watertight text which doesn't
encroach on the competence of member
states it simply guarantees fundamental
principles the independence to the free
media in a well-functioning democracy
the media board will follow on from the
air again clearly it has to be
independent from everybody including
from the commission thanks to the work
of the parliament thanks to the work of
the committee and Daniel freund the
commission could already intervene more
strenuously
if it
if it wasn't um
following um EU legislation in in the um
avsma D or the DSA
we need to guarantee the independence of
the board is essential
whatever the political color of of the
commission the important thing is that
the board is independent
regardless of you know whether the
commission um
is of one political Hue or another uh I
think the Libya committees compromise uh
rules out what was criticized by Mrs
silchich the protection of sources uh
should not be subject to spying and
uh any uh spyware would require
um a legal order and article 17 let me
clarify Media Services
should not be dependent on the the
arbitrary decisions of national uh
regulatory boards if they come into
conflict with the views of the platforms
they can turn directly to the European
board and explain their positions so
there are all sorts of safeguards built
in to avoid interference from third
countries to avoid political uh
arbitrary decisions and
institutional arbitrary decisions so uh
it does offer safeguards and guarantees
it is a balanced and legally watertight
legislative text so I would urge you to
vote in favor of this today so that we
can really protect media freedom and
also freedom and democracy
and I would like to thank the commission
once again for the constructive
cooperation and also look forward to
cooperation with the Spanish presidency
and I do hope that we will manage to get
this file through before the end of the
year thank you very much
excellent thank you very much this
brings the debate to a conclusion as you
know we will be voting on this file
today we can continue our sitting now
with the commemoration of the 10 year
anniversary of the tragedy in lampedusa
with a statement by the president thank
you